yeah boy yeah welcome to the very first
stream hopefully working yeah is welcome
softener sighs I don't we couldn't
afford jacksepticeye so we have Brad
here. I regret this...So much.
I get to bridge in the British it's
hundred percent British no one else does
it cuz Marzia had never heard of a
sausage roll ever but like everyone in
this country knows or sausage roll is
it's very like famous yeah and you
didn't what just happened what the hell
was that Thank You Hannah China fucking
can you move on you can just see it
looks disgusting all right ready I want
you to it okay hmm okay ah it's even
better with the sort of sexual / times
and I do drone Wars robot war activate
so what is framework because you ingrate
this and didn't tell me I thank you like
almost everything you do shut up please
we have our droning they're gonna fight
all right this is four point okay very
serious how do we make them play that's
a good question cuz we have here oh my
gosh where we can modify we got spray
paint we got I don't know how this will
help fighting you know this might not be
approved by twitch but we have weapons
as well so that we can modify the most
powerful unique most advanced technology
known to man a plastic fork if you're
gonna go right into them as I I'm gonna
have a pilot come on yeah good luck with
that you're gonna lose I always watch
his twitch montages where people get
like big donations and they like oh my
god
what did you get that I've saved it huh
what did you do I think I activated the
new new activation you got a new shit
alright Chad which one do you think is
gonna win comment down below you place
your bets Jeff Gould them or Channing
Tatum oh oh yeah yeah Jeff wait wait
don't know why is he doing that why is
it doing that ah no don't snot to watch
TV either that's too expensive
orchestral hey mitch is something cheap
a midget something cheap hahaha anything
with the camera Jim yeah yeah that's
right boy fuck you get gold one I mean
Channing Tatum oh no oh yeah sorry time
with you suck ha ha ha ha ha ha
now there's a random person in this
wheel all right we don't know who we
didn't make these we're going to pick
around a person then we're going to pick
a random topic we want everyone who's
watching the stream right now this is
extremely important whatever happens in
the world right now doesn't matter we
need to do this we need everyone to
tweak this person this topic for example
Kanye West giraffe all right a good
example don't do it and it's for a noble
cause our entertainment yes okay why
don't you even start spinning can we get
some bingo music going on here keep
spinning no no no no no he's gonna break
it keep spinning he would normally be
this side of the person and he does this
little time all he does is that and then
the interview someone for about two
seconds who is that mighty knows Jimmy
Fallon Jimmy power Jimmy Fallon a fella
you're about to get the sweet love a
Twitter roll and hold your horses we
don't know what we don't know what to
tweet we're gonna tweet on Mac oh it
fell out right away oh my god i fell out
right away alright are we ready it's not
funny it came funny because it's such a
weird memphis hang gliding hang gliding
jimmy fallon find a picture of hang
gliding tweeted to Jimmy Fallon brother
Myrnin Julia laddie what's your favorite
color green your favorite color is green
did you know that's my pubes are green
yeah they're laying right here actually
what the fuck so the motor half replace
them on Jack where they belong that's
correct a weird fact I've seen
jacksepticeye dude it's really weird
yeah genuineness in a big pig do you
have your dress on I think people want
to see that well here's the thing we
should do
secretly he'll wait 3000 but wait is
that my that's my donation take it I
take it up take it up take it up take it
up take it up big vehicles around which
is why washing with fooling tiny little
oh no no they're doing further working
with my nipples allow ah which means the
bra is ineffective of what the reason
I'm wearing the rock yeah boy that
covers right yeah yeah there this is so
weird I never been too scared in my life
you yeah i'm just getting naked I like
it this is what I want you look so weird
this is so weird like what are we doing
here why are we still here all right
there we go so difficult ok I think
we're way past 10 minutes now so can we
speed up the margin damn girl you look
good better socks and sandals but is it
really bad I can both i can i can i get
i mean what do you want her looking for
I'm way less like liable for like
everything i say i think it sucks and
tentative fine oh you just alright i'll
vote against yellow sandals I don't see
the big deal alright if I want to wear
something said I actually do it you got
a problem with that and you pick on me
for being an old man and this is
actually what you do might say you like
when I where the stock themselves right
well maybe she did now she did she
didn't shitty no well there you go my
argument is that the whole point of like
wearing nice clothes to appeal to my
dear why you never tell me this yeah she
said I don't like his slippers in
general by the way I don't know how bad
the sound the white hot i think i win
and i didn't say a word
this one comes from Barry from Scotland
bear from Scotland do the accent when
you revisit all right RRR ferry from a
pirate ship uh where can I find the most
top quality of memes are very I'm very
from Scotland a good fire uh well I
don't know there's this fresh new meme
call like it's from the movie 28 Jump
Street tell me the name I've never heard
of this one so there's just one part
where Channing Tatum has to pretend that
he's Mexican all right so he says my
name is Jeff really everyone is talking
about I just don't want to do when we
put it off the mall can we put on some
romantic music give me my phone throw it
again don't know what I'm we can't put
on my my name you ah no like curb your
enthusiasm there's like one of us aside
we are this is it this is basically
thank you for watching Thank You the
word day the best club I will see you
guys next week then can we cut this
right as we kiss ver about the kids can
you let you spot on my hand stop coming
out you're not gonna pee myself I gotta
pee so back this is the word how do you
do this I said how do you kissing my
mighty rose look at me sounds like a mud
yeah no look at me look at me Jeremy
I got another confession to make
are y'all
look at me look at me ah listen it is
Tony laughs yeah